This is Radiolab. I'm Jad
Abumrad. And I'm Robert Krulwich.
In this hour we are
looking at [inaudible].
Wait.
Oh, who was that? I'm sorry.
Okay, here we have the laugh box.
That's a strange little device that
Robert Provan from the University of
Maryland Plate. Remember him from the
previous heck yeah, he played it to me.
And he has
the notion about this. Yeah. So basically
you just need laughter, you know,
cause weapon. The notion here is you
don't need a joke to start the laugh.
All you need is a laugh. You can throw
the joke away. Laughter causes laughter.
No, you can't get a
laugh going from there.
Well actually actually you can.
And he said I'll prove it to you.
So he showed me a video tape.
This was at in the mall.
Excuse me. Hi. We're doing a study on
the laughter. Laughter. A good thing.
Absolutely. You'll laugh a lot. I
laugh every day. I make my wife laugh.
All ready. What do you
do that makes him laugh?
Trip spills a lot of things.
What are the thing? We have
a piece of apparatus here.
You pushed the button before
[inaudible]
why were you laughing?
Did anyone tell a joke?
Anyone do anything funny,
easy. What's true? Provide is
absolutely correct about this.
What we're dealing here is
something that's very contagious.
[inaudible] um, I'm, I'll go gray.
All right. Well, well while we are on
the subject of contagious laughter,
I've got a story to tell you.
We are filming.
You want to, all right, now
imagine you Whitney. Yeah.
Imagine 1960 [inaudible] I would just
sit here, eyes your attention. I mean,
Oh yes. 1962. Yeah. Rural village of
Catia, Tanzania, girls boarding school.
When a girl is sitting in
class, she begins to laugh.
The girl next to her maybe
turned left. Here's her laugh.
And she begins to cross the classroom
with their girl joins in and the teacher
gets upset, but it's too
soon for girls in eighth.
The entire class has begun to
laugh and then cry and then laugh,
cry and the cow. What? Just cause
I don't know. [inaudible] anyhow,
a girl outside at that moment,
walking down the hall to imagine she
hears the laughter from the classroom.
She started still laugh.
And as she walks in,
laughs her laughter goes into other
classrooms and soon the whole school is
doing this laughing,
crying, laughing, crying.
Teachers cannot control these girls
when they try to, the girls get violent,
they could play one. Yup. And
the principal then has choice.
He's got to close the school.
They opened the school a week
later and it happens again soon.
They closed the school a second time.
Meanwhile, the girls who started all this,
they go back to their villages many,
many miles away and this thing,
whatever it is, spreads up and down
the coast of Lake Victoria. You mean?
People in the villages start
to play in one village,
217 people start to laugh and cry.
A second boarding school has to
shut down and no one knows why.
So a team of doctors,
some British doctors in the area and they
hop in a land rover and they rush out
to investigate this strange phenomenon
and this is what they write. The
Central African Journal of Medicine,
volume nine number five, May,
1963 the disease commenced
on 30th of January,
1962 to mission among girls
and middle school at Kosha.
The onset is sudden with a tax of laughing
and crying lasting for a few minutes
to a few hours to a maximum of 16 days
by spite and then a recurrence in the
report there was an account of a 52 year
old man who saw some people afflicted
with a sickness. I'm soon after
we're turning to his heart,
he felt something telling him to
laugh and cry and shout. There's,
he continued to do for most of the night.
No fatal cases have been reported.
This is very, what is this true?
Well, okay. We wondered. Okay.
So we sent our producer Ellen Horn 40
some odd years after the fact to see what
she could find.
I'm flying to [inaudible] to be honest,
I was a little bit worried that I can
see the sun setting over Lake Victoria
that uh, that the medical
journal article just wasn't true.
Yes. With that's yeah. Cause
that's cause what I expected.
Was this a total hoax? Yeah.
Or that it was some kind of
like stunt getting close.
It just sort of doubted the general
credibility of the, of the whole thing.
Okay. We'll be correcting
the BACOPA. Okay.
So I get to recall baptist totally
in the most beautiful place.
The cover is a tiny port town.
It's green and lush and this very
remote part of northern Tanzania in the
morning.
And my first step was just to spend a
couple of days walking around and asking
everybody that I ran
into who spoke English.
So I'm asking them about
this contagious laughter,
but demic of laughter I
guess I imagined, you know,
this happened in the in the sixties so
I'm looking for people who are like in
their seventies and eighties turns out
that I didn't need old people and young
people totally new. But I
was talking about I, yeah,
I totally know what you mean
because it still happens today.
The first time I saw it,
it was in 1991 I went to this tour office
and the first person I met there was
this guy named Raymond Raymond.
When he said he thought he could find me,
somebody who had I maybe forgive
me three hours, I can find those.
I can give you my phone number.
About an hour later I get
a text from him that says,
meet me in a half hour hop
in his car. We drive off to,
how did you find this person? I know
he's not kidding. Raymond is a former
Tanzania national soccer team star.
He's like a local celebrity, like
kids follow him down the street,
so Raymond drives me up this dirt road
about 10 minutes we get to this blue
cement building.
We sit outside on the porch and these
white plastic chairs and we just, we wait.
Hello. After about 20 minutes, this
woman comes out really beautiful,
has a mole on her nose at long eyelashes
or she'll introduce herself for me.
She's nervously squeezing this plastic
water bottle. It's in her hand.
[inaudible] can Chester is her name.
[inaudible].
She tells me that in her high school
there were three girls who are affected
chicka Chicka for all of them
in happen during exams. Yeah.
What do you remember what the test was
about? It was the
morning of the math test.
She remembers walking into
the exam room. She sat down,
she looked at her paper and suddenly
[inaudible] something came over her.
She started laughing and
then she took a photo class
C and e community and then she says she
doesn't remember much ups from that.
She's told that she fought.
When they tried to restrain her,
she spent three days in the
hospital. They would give her Valium,
make her pass out. Then she'd wake up,
feel a little bit better for a while
and then it would come on again.
She'd uncontrollably be laughing.
Then they would give her more Valium.
She'd pass out. Why do
you think this happens?
A little gun in a c tree, she says,
happens for girls, right, are not free.
And so I asked her if she felt free,
like I'm not even sure
what they're talking about,
but I asked her if she
felt free and she said,
I need a quote or I can establish
you live with your parents,
what can you're that age,
no one's really free.
She said she had a boyfriend and her
parents wouldn't let her see him.
But in the hospital when she
had the laughing sickness,
he was allowed to come
visit and he definitely
[inaudible].
So this girl has a crazy
attack of laughing and then
her boyfriend shows up and
she's just fine. Well, we're more like,
she's allowed to see her boyfriend.
So it's about the wall. She's, I mean,
the real common association with this,
with the sicknesses that
it's a teenage girl disease
happens to grow. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Again,
16 to 20 years old crying and sometimes
laughy talk to a school nurse,
a psychiatric nurse from the
local hospital, a doctor,
and they all said vaguely the same thing.
The reason it happened was that it had
something to do with the transitions of
adolescence. And, and just out
of curiosity, you're a girl.
Is there something about this that
makes sense to you? Terrorists. Yes.
Out of Cura. Yeah, sure.
So do you know you're just beginning to
kind of negotiate your relationship to
sex and boys and there's
these new pressures and these
new responsibilities that
are really challenging. It's funny,
boys don't, don't have that problem.
We just want to have sex and
it's a crisis for girls. Yeah.
So it does kind of make sense. Okay.
But it doesn't really explain
anything about 1962 to me. Why not?
Because in 1962 it wasn't just teenage
girls, it was boys. It was men.
It was villages full
of people of all ages.
So what explains that?
[inaudible]
personally for me, found a
woman who was there. Hello.
That's good.
Gertrude is in her fifties she's got
short loose curls and big smiles.
And in 1962 when the laughter epidemic
struck her village, she got it too.
Six years old.
Very young. Do you remember?
I remember his, yeah.
Sheer ever seen hundreds of people
coming down with this strange affliction.
I took many forms. Some were
laughing, everlasting laughter,
then laugh and cry at the
same thing at the same time.
[inaudible]
what happened to me was
I was not able to talk,
crying only,
and then my eyes were closed as
if there is a it gum on my eyes,
so my mom,
she called me on her back and they walked.
They walked over the hills when her mom
carrying her on her back for hours and
along the way, they ran into other
people, boys, girls, men even. Oh,
Dylan's dozens of people all headed
the same way. Laughing, crying.
I have been yet the skin.
Where are they going to?
The witch doctor did this. Which
note? I didn't know what else to do.
[inaudible] hundreds of people. She
says, converged on this woman's tiny hut,
so do going east. A 10 by 10 in
the house. They will have fool.
They hit to stay outside.
They are mini because there were so
many people going to many people.
Those daily, Boom. What do you
think the problem was? Oh, okay.
I was asking my Erda ones
Tuesday problem.
They said that it was
something like spiritual,
a spiritual event,
because one year before this program
there we are sitting in seats.
She said that about a year
before the laughter epidemic,
Caterpillar's had shown up.
They were breathing in the
spread all over the ground.
There was this huge infestation.
One of the explanations was that the
people who got sick had walked across the
caterpillar. They stepped on this
caterpillars and had killed them.
As a result,
the spirit of the caterpillars were
possessing they that they to get this
feeling. Now she sort of dismissed
that. That's not scientific,
but maybe this caterpillar head is
eating bacterias which affected debris.
Okay.
This explanation that there was some
sort of bacteria or virus I had already
checked today,
I had gone to the Government Hospital
[inaudible] to talk to the medical officer
and insurance. They've never
found any physical costs for this.
Not in the medical
importance, which was found.
I'd even talked to a lab technician.
I've looked at the technician who had
checked blood samples in 1962 everything
was negative. They tested the
water supply, the food supply.
You get people negative so that the
cattle fillers seemed like a dead end.
So I tried a different tech.
I asked Gertrude what was going on then
at that time in your village and she
thought about it for awhile and then
she said you look well he's winning.
Of course there was
independence. Independence.
Whoa.
For 40 years Tanzania had been a British
colony but 1961 Tanzania had declared
independence and this was right before,
just weeks before that
first girl started laughing.
[inaudible] I don't know
much about independence.
What can you tell me about independence?
What they experienced by then was
people going alone seeing Ethan drums.
Dan seeing cause the [inaudible]
but the but from that I can tell more
routine dependence cause I was very,
very young.
Gertrude said that she knew
somebody who would remember more.
Someone I should talk to.
[inaudible] 71 year old man.
Mr Sauce was se thing deal, which
looked at, he was the witchdoctors.
This assistant may be,
this man can help more than I do.
You want some coffee or some
breakfast here first, how?
My very last day in the Cobra,
Raymond and I sat down with this map
and which doctor's assistant had a
restaurant near my hotel. It's a tiny guy,
gray hair and big oversized suit and he
filled in some of the missing pieces.
When you tell him, I want
to know what he remembers.
I asked him about the independence
celebration that Gertrude described.
[inaudible] the ones just
before the laughter epidemic.
[inaudible] he painted a very
different picture. I didn't remember
[inaudible]. He was 26 at the time.
Kenny MCHA is teens and after
the parties died down, he said,
change [inaudible] swept
through his village to do jewel.
Does that Buddha? It can
you cut out cause I would've
[inaudible] [inaudible]
following independence,
Tanzania became a socialist state and the
new government was out to create a new
world order. Lamb changed hands.
They abolished the local clan,
the president, president [inaudible].
After the independence
and the local religions,
the bond, the speech,
this was the brand new
age. This is the new era.
You were supposed to have
a modern belief system.
The entire village was being asked to
abandon the way that they had worshiped
for thousands of years. You can tweak it
[inaudible] within weeks. The church
has moved out. Yeah, but it's okay. Lee,
they had business. Catholic church
opened up on one side of the street.
Now Lutheran on the other patients
were [inaudible] people convincing
[inaudible] to join different really
tins. They even handed out money.
It was kind of a bidding war for
souls. All of it was too new,
too fast. The tool does
that. Buddha Sassy,
he even remembers this one
particular night that would assassin.
Everyone in his village gathered outside.
Rafa stared at the Sky Kupuna and whizzy
they had been told that was the end of
life on f uh,
to me the night everybody was out the
all night waiting to see whether the moon
today, a couple of hours,
he told me we saw that
heavens and the moon.
She did too slamming into each other.
Can you cut out cause I've sequel
[inaudible] what they saw, it was a
scoped them. That's what they see.
Got It. Maybe that was the end
of the world of that old world.
Here's the sky,
the switched doctors assistant who
introduced himself to me actually as an
elected official made this jump in his
life that that was a particular period of
time when everybody was making
this big jump all of the sudden.
So you think that this laughing
epidemic had something to do with it?
Like an avalanche of newness? Yeah,
well the explanations I came across,
this is the one that makes the most
sense to me. It's plausible to me too,
cause you're, you got a loss of
religion and arrival of a new religion,
a loss of a political
culture, a new leader.
And that's a very large pile up
of change all of a sudden. Yeah.
And of course everyone's
a little bit scared.
So there's a quiet and then
someone starts to laugh. You know,
who knows why that first girl went
crazy and why she started making crazy
laughing noises. But it was like people
saw that and they were like, Oh God,
I feel like that too.
It sounds like laughter.
But you could think of it as as like a
collective scream or something. Yeah,
like the entire society
was a 16 year old girl
[inaudible]
in 1962 Radiolab producer
Elena morn. Well,
that's it for us, at least for now,
for information on the Tanzanian left
epidemic or anything else you've heard in
this hour, visit radiolab.org I'm Jab Ron,
and I remember quote, we'll see later.
Radio lab is produced by Jad Abumrad,
Lulu Miller, Rob Christensen,
Ellen Horn, Elizabeth [inaudible].
It's production support, production
production support by Sally hardships.
Sarah Pellegrini, Arielle Laskey,
Heather Radke, Michael Orion
muck, Madison, Soren Wheeler.
Thanks to Gail cleaver, Beth
Barack, Bingo nightly, Emily Webber,
and Sharon Hill. Finally special
thanks to Casey Crawford.